problema número 30 y el siguiente
círculo con centro en o qué fracción
está asombrada tenemos que encontrar
cuál es el porcentaje del total de
grados del círculo que está sombreado
veámoslo de esta manera si estos son 150
grados cuál será el ángulo de acá
cuál será este ángulo bueno pues estos
son ángulos suplementarios es decir la
suma de estos dos nos debe dar 180
grados 30 más 150 es igual a 180 así que
este ángulo será de 30 grados
estos dos ángulos son opuestos así que
son iguales o también lo pueden ver con
el mismo principio de acá 150 grados y
este pedacito que falta para completar
el medio círculo los 180 grados pues 150
más 30 también serán 180 grados
entonces cuál es la medida total de los
ángulos sombreados pues 30 30 va a ser
igual a 60 para encontrar el porcentaje
lo que vamos a hacer es tomar estos 60
grados sombreados y dividirlo entre los
360 grados totales del círculo y esto va
a ser igual
quitamos estos 0 26 por 16 6 por 6 36 un
sexto una sexta parte del círculo está
asombrada y esta es nuestra opción c
veamos el siguiente problema si a leo le
toma 11 segundos correr 100 metros
cuántos segundos le tomara a correr x
metros a la misma velocidad leo va a una
velocidad de 10 metros metros
sobre o entre 11 segundos
cuanto a tomar a recorrer x metros
tratamos de comprender esto con
cantidades digamos que el correr 5
metros por segundo vamos a inventar este
dato eso es lo que él corre cuando le
toman a recorrer no sé 10 metros cuánto
le toma a recorrer 10 metros
bueno esos 10 metros lo dividimos entre
5 metros por segundo
10 metros / 5 metros sobre segundo y
esto va a ser igual a 10 es en 35 es 2
segundos de la misma forma su velocidad
es de entre 11 metros por segundo
james entre 11 metros por segundo y
queremos saber cuánto tarda en recorrer
x metros así que va a ser x / x metros /
y / 11
esto es lo mismo que tener esto es igual
tener x x 11 / g
que es igual a 11 x entre 10 segundos
otra forma de verlo es que si estos
metros entre 11 segundos es igual a la
velocidad si esto es velocidad velocidad
la distancia entre el tiempo desde el
primer curso de física nos dicen que la
distancia es igual a la velocidad por el
tiempo y nos preguntan la distancia así
que la distancia x igual a la velocidad
de entre 11 por el tiempo si queremos
conocer el tiempo pues vamos a despejar
esto y nos va a quedar que el tiempo es
igual a x / g / 11 y tenemos este mismo
desarrollo que es igual a 11 x entre
ella que es nuestra opción a siguiente
problema
pero tiene 10 pares de calcetines que
combinan es decir 10 pares de calcetines
pares si él pierde 7 calcetines
individuales cuál es el mayor número de
pares de calcetines que combinan es
decir de padres de pares que le quedan
bueno entonces aquí el buen al pierde 7
calcetines solitos pierde 7 calcetines
calcetines pensamos al respecto
el peor escenario bueno pues es el caso
en el que cada uno de estos calcetines
perdidos sean diferentes y pertenezcan a
pares distintos pero lo que nos
preguntan es el mejor escenario y esto
es que estos siete calcetines la mayor
cantidad sean pares
y esto de esto sería que tres pares que
serían seis calcetines pero tres pares
se pierdan tres pares
a uno que no es paz que es no un
calcetín suelto es el que se perdió
ese es el mejor escenario y en ese caso
nos quedaríamos con qué bueno perdió
tres pares así que le quedarían siete
pares pero como perdió un calcetín
suelto pues eso les hace un par
entonces le quedan solamente seis pares
completos seis pares
que es nuestra opción b
si nos hubieran preguntado el peor
escenario cada uno de los siete
calcetines destruiría un par así que de
los diez pares que tenía al menos siete
impares pues sólo quedarían tres pares
veamos el siguiente problema 33 cuales
el menor entero positivo que es
invisible por cada uno de los números
del 1 al 7 incluyendo los es decir
incluyendo el 1 e incluyendo al 7
entonces son los números que van del 1
al 7 incluyendo estos dos el número va a
tener que ser divisible en 377 es primo
no lo puedo combinar con otros números
solo tiene otros factores más que el
mismo y uno también va a ser divisible
entre 6
lo puedo factorizar como un 3 por 1 2 ya
verán por qué estoy haciendo esto
también tiene que ser divisible entre 55
es primo no puedo factorizar lo entonces
tengo que dejarlo así por 5 luego tiene
también que ser divisible entre 44 lo
puedo factorizar como 2 por 2
aquí ya tengo un 2 y como quiero el
mínimo entero pues voy a ahorrarme
términos y aquí solo lo voy a
multiplicar por 2 estos 2 por 2 me va a
dar un 4 y ya con esto cumple que es
divisible entre 4 tiene que ser
divisible entre 3 también pero aquí ya
tengo un 3 así que esto ya lo tengo
contemplado tiene que ser difícil entre
2 aquí bueno ya tengo 2 y bueno
finalmente divisible entre 1 que todos
son divisibles entre una ahí no tengo
problema entonces lo que voy a hacer es
multiplicar cada uno de estos elementos
para obtener cuál es el número más
pequeño que es divisible entre todos
estos números
así que es 7 por 3 21 por 2 42 por 5 5
por 2 10 5 por 4 20 + 1 21 210 por 2 420
así que esta es mi respuesta es el
número más pequeño que cumple con esta
regla que es divisible entre todos los
números del 1 al 7 y corresponde a mi
opción a siguiente problema que el
porcentaje de 30 es 12 para encontrar
esto podemos decir que 12 es igual a
equis que x es un número decimal por 30
es decir qué porcentaje este es mi
incógnita la x de 30 es 2 y
eventualmente podremos convertir esto de
decimal a porcentaje de multiplicar la
porción así que despejamos nuestro
incógnita que es x es igual a 12 entre
qué número tenemos en común arriba y
abajo 3 x 4 12 3 por 10 33 es un factor
que puedo sacar cuatro décimos y esto lo
puedo expresar
punto 4 este es mi número decimal ahora
si yo quiero tener esto en porcentaje lo
multiplicó por 100 punto 4 por 100 es
igual a 40%
el 12 es el 40 por ciento de 30 esta es
mi opción de
esto puede ser confuso así que es
importante escribirlo bien qué
porcentaje de 30 es 12 será un número
más pequeño que el 30 entonces qué
porcentaje de 30 es 12 hacemos esta
división y esto me va a dar igual a ese
porcentaje que es mi incógnita que acabo
de resolver acá muy bien pasamos al
último problema de este vídeo
si 1.5 entre punto 2 + x es igual a 5 a
que será igual x pues vamos a resolver
vamos a multiplicar ambos lados por
punto 2 + x esto 1.5 entre puntos 2 + x
igual a 5 si ambos lados lo
multiplicamos por punto 2 + x
2x y aquí también punto 2 + x
este se va con este me queda 1.5 igual a
5 por punto 2 va a ser 10 y con el lugar
decimal va a ser 11 más 5 por x 5 x
ok nos interesa x entonces vamos a
restar 1 en ambos lados de esta ecuación
así que es menos 1 más 1.5 y a esto le
restamos menos 1 o bueno le restamos 1
este se va - 11.5 me va a quedar punto 5
igual a 5 x divido todo entre 5.5 entre
55 x entre 5 estos se van punto 5 entre
5 va a ser igual a punto 1.1 es igual a
equis y esta es mi opción de excelente
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo